PROFESSOR: A Very important
property of a numerical method
is its order.
The accuracy of the method
is proportional to a power
of the step size.
And that power is
called the order.
If h is the step size
and p is the order,
then the error
made in one step is
proportional to h
to the p plus 1.
And the error made in
traversing an entire interval is
proportional to H to the p.
So this means, if you're
using a method of order p,
and cut the step
size in half, you
can expect the overall error
to be reduced by a factor of 2
to the p.
The order of a numerical method
is determined by analysis
involving Taylor series during
the derivation of the method.
But we can also do an experiment
to determine the order.
That's what this program does.
The input is the name
of an ODE solver.
And then it's going to do
a numerical integration
of an ordinary differential
equation, just involving t.
So the result is the
value of an integral.
The integral of 1 over 1
plus t squared, from 0 to 1.
We know the exact answer is 1/2.
So we integrate that
differential equation twice,
once with a step size of
0.1, and then with a step
size of one half that.
We integrate the
differential equation,
take the final value of y for
each of those two integrations,
compare those values
with the exact answer,
take the ratio of
those two values.
That shows how much the
error is decreased when
we cut the step size in half.
The log base 2 of that
ratio is the order.
It should be an integer so we
can round it to the nearest
integer, and return that value
as the value in this function.
Let's run our experiment
first on ODE1.
We step size of 0.1, this method
gets the integral as 0.5389,
not very accurate.
Cut the step size in
half, it gets 0.5191.
The ratio of those is two.
Logarithm base 2 is 1.
So ODE1 has order 1.
Now ODE2-- step size 0.1.
0.499.
cut it in half, 0.4998.
The ratio of those
is close to 4.
And so ODE2, we find with this
experiment, is getting order 2.
Now let's try
classical Runge-Kutta.
This is why it's so popular.
It's very accurate.
We step size of 0.1,
we get close to 1/2.
Cut the step size in
half, we get even closer.
The ratio of these
two is close to 16.
To the log base 2 is 4.
So ODE4 has,
experimentally, order 4.
So we found that, at least
with this single experiment,
the ODE solvers 1, 2, and
4, have orders 1, 2, and 4.
So as you probably
realized, this
is why we named them
ODE 1, 2, and 4.
This brings us to the naming
conventions in the functions
in the MATLAB ODE suite.
All the functions
have names that are
variations on the theme ODEpq.
That means that the method ODEpq
uses methods of order p and q
So we've been getting a glimpse
of that with our names, ODE 1,
2, and 4.
Here's an exercise.
Modify order x to do further
experiments involving
the order of our ODE solvers.
Change it to do other integrals.
And check out the order
of ODE 1, 2, and 4.